Today, in our Little Yellow Book,
she's an inspiration to all of us.
You have her on your wall in your show. It's Oprah.
(crowd cheers)
Oprah!
Thank you, everyone.
Oprah?!
I know, yeah, it's like, yeah!
Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah!
(laughs)
I love that she said, "live your best life".
How clever is that? The turn of phrase,
"your" makes it about you, and not about her.
And now we have Oprah Daily, which is like,
lets you just know you can be on that feeder
and totally satisfied.
And she has a new digital series on the oprahdaily.com,
called the "Oprah Daily Insiders Round Table".
It's hosted by the one and only Gayle King,
who's a friend of the show.
Love Gayle.
And mine, and with incredible guests like Glennon Doyle,
Ashley C. Ford, talking about the big issues.
Let's take a look.
It's like, we have had time to think about who we are
and what we want and what we will not accept anymore,
whether it's stilettos or that jerk that we've been going
to lunch with forever, for some reason.
It's being fiercely on our own side,
and not changing for the world,
but like, changing our friends and our clothes to fit us.
(crowd cheers)
Huh, I feel like our conversations could cross over.
A hundred thousand percent.
Glennon Doyle kind of talking fun truths about fashion
and relationships, and breaking it all down
in a pithy, adorable, useful takeaway, way.
I was... I'm on Oprah Daily,
and she published her journal entry from the night before
she started the Oprah Winfrey Show.
Oh, wow!
So, as a journalist...
"Journalist".
(crowd laughs)
I wanted to read that entry so badly.
So I go to read it and they're like,
"Oh, you have to be an Oprah Insider to get it."
And I was like... (screams)
So, are you an Oprah Insider?
I want to be.
All right.
Well, you can be.
And we are thrilled because we are teaming up
with Oprah Daily for an ongoing partnership.
Oprah Daily editors will be sharing the latest
Oprah Daily scoops here all season long,
and we're kicking it off today!
(crowd cheers and whoops)
Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah!
You're all getting a free Oprah Daily Insider membership!
(crowd cheers)
Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah! Oprah!
Whoo, go! That's a full year of the magazine, digital,
and all the episodes of Oprah Daily Insiders Round Table,
special invites, so much more.
So I'm just... I'm thrilled.
I'm excited to spend every day with Oprah.
She is an icon.
But you're an icon, and I'm an icon,
and you're all icons!
(crowd cheers)
That's right!
Wow!
Ziwe Fumudoh, thank you for being the best co-pilot,
here today, on the news.
(upbeat music)